uh what did you make of criticism of
nurses by some of Mr gog's colleagues in
the papers this morning
I think it's appalling I mean don't
forget that Simon Clark who made those
comments was the leveling up secretary
until relatively recently uh trusted by
the Tories to hold a cabinet post and is
now lecturing nurses about their need to
budget at a time when most people
working in the National Health Service
are really really struggling we were
clapping for them as Heroes not very
long ago and you know there's one thing
I do agree with Michael Gove about it's
that they deserve our respect and our
support but most of all they deserve a
government that gets around the table
and negotiates with them they don't want
to be out on strike the public don't
want to see these strikes the only
people who seem to want to provoke us
into this standoff is the government who
just won't sit down and sort this out
um do you also agree with him that it is
inappropriate for the nurses and
ambulance workers and 999 call handlers
all to go on strike on the same day
people will die surely
look I I think that the biggest safety
crisis in the National Health Service at
the moment is because we have burnt out
staff and not enough people I went into
my local a e Department which you'll
know very well came Wigan last week and
I found nurses working around the clock
really really struggling to keep morale
up because this is not the sort of care
they want to provide to people what
they're trying to do is meet minimum
safety standards so they can care for
people safely safely and at times they
feel that they're not even able to meet
that the management there left me in no
doubt that these nurses these paramedics
they are standing up not just for
themselves but for the National Health
Service and the problem that we've got
in this government is not militant
workers it's a militant government
who will be responsible if people die on
the 6th of February because the
ambulance workers the 999 call handlers
and the nurses are all on strike at the
same time the government Bears entire
responsibility for this for months the
health secretary has been refusing to
even meet the workforce to talk to them
about their concerns this isn't just
about pay it's also about conditions
it's about the fact that we don't have
enough people in the National Health
Service and because of the way that
ministers have treated people in the NHS
over the last year we've got more and
more people saying to MPS like me I
don't know if I can carry on like this I
just don't know if I can stay that is
completely and utterly unsustainable the
Royal College of Nursing in unison told
us that although the recent meeting with
the health secretary long overdue
resulted in a change of tone what it
hasn't resulted in is a change of
approach we've got to treat this
seriously we've got to treat our
Frontline Workforce as partners there
isn't a huge amount of money around
particularly since the Tories crash the
economy so we've got to take seriously
the fact that we've got people on the
front line saying you need help now it's
one of the reasons why we've said that
we were taxed non-doms properly and we
would get that money International
Health Service and raise Staffing levels
so that we don't have nurses on the
front line telling us that it's
fundamentally unsafe
okay talk to me about leveling up a 2.1
billion pounds from round two of the
government's leveling up fund at the
North West getting 350 million pounds
from that pot it's the highest amount
per region you must be pleased with that
look in Wigan we've we've been
successful in our bid finally we're
unsuccessful last time and we will
welcome any money back that the
government chooses to give us we badly
need investment but it equates to only a
fifth of the money that they've taken
from us since Boris Johnson promised in
2019 to level up the country it's and
most places have lost four out of five
places that asked for some money have
got none at all and even the winners are
losing because it's the equivalent of
handling a Survivor and making 20 quid
out of our back pocket we can do better
than this Hunger Games style contest
where we pit councils and communities
against one another we need a long-term
sustained effort from the government to
raise their ambition and to help us grow
what are really exciting Industries in
the north of England whether it's the
film industry in the northeast or
hydrogen in Ellesmere Port this is the
chance to get good jobs back into
communities and money back into people's
pockets and a High Street streets
thriving again and instead he's got
these one-off pots of funding of our
money and we're expected to be grateful
it takes an extraordinary arrogance from
government to think that we should be
running around celebrating when all
they're doing is giving the small
amounts of our own money back
the average rent in Wigan is 1100 pounds
a month do you think people who are
struggling to pay that
um care at all that's a grade two listed
building is having a bit of a makeover
we're extremely proud of hey Hall it's
one of the most beautiful places in the
country and there's far more that we can
do to showcase our culture and our
heritage if we get proper investment
from government so we're proud of that
we've got an exhibition planned by
Theodore major one of the greatest
artists in the country who was from
Wigan he should be a household name and
with the efforts of wooden Council and
the people who again he will be but for
goodness sake we've got people
struggling to pay their mortgages we've
got people struggling to pay their rents
we've got the value of wages falling the
problem we've got like every part of the
country is that we can't go out and
spend on the High Street when we haven't
got good jobs and money in our pockets
and choices and chances for young people
so they don't have to get out to get on
we could create that if the government's
not micromanaging decisions about little
pots of funding bridges in Cumbria
picnic areas in the Northeast traffic
lights in Harrogate all decisions that
Michael Gove and his colleagues have
exerted an iron grip over over the last
few years it's had a micro managing
those decisions from Westminster and
Whitehall hand over power and resources
and let us build a country that works
well you say that but treasury analysis
I'm looking at since the 6th of January
says that labors announced
45.2 billion pounds in spending
commitments leading to a proposed rise
of 1650 pounds in tax per household per
year
that's not doable is it well it's also
not true I've seen that analysis and it
includes things like free covid tests
which we said should continue to be made
available during the pandemic we haven't
made any kind of long-term commitment to
free covid tests for life this is a
desperate government out of energy out
of ideas we've been absolutely clear
that we're not going to borrow to fund
day-to-day spending because it's
people's money and they haven't got a
lot of it particularly at the moment
since list trust crashed the economy but
we are going to invest in the future of
this country for the long term because
we believe that we can do better than
these small pots and money on offer to
places that have seen a decade of Decay
and decline we have a contribution to
make across the north of England and in
every region and nation in this country
and we're in a government that raises
its game backs us with real powers real
funding you can bet if you've handed
over the powers and the funding for
Northern Powerhouse rail to the north of
England without constant government
interference we'd have done on it by now
give us the power give us the resources
and we'll show you what we can do
your lead has just released a video
talking about I mean you're a party of
the people is the point that he's trying
to make talks about how he grew up in a
pebble-70 detached house he shared a
bedroom bunk beds
um with his brother when he was growing
up now he's in Davos rubbing shoulders
with the um Literati uh which message
should we take
well we met no apology for saying that
the Global Financial system has to work
for people in places like Wigan and
right across the country take the global
minimum corporation tax which Joe Biden
successfully pressed for this is
millions of pounds that was bleeding out
of our communities and our Public
Services because countries were in a
race to the bottom trying to attract
Global corporations who didn't pay their
fair share of tax we are we make no
apology for the fact that we will go
wherever it takes to fight for the
interests of the people of this country
but the difference between us and the
Tories is that we don't just go to those
places and schmooze we go and fight for
a fairer system and we make no apology
for that
um yeah but I mean do you really need to
go to Davos in order to make that point
I think you have to go and talk to
people like-minded governments in order
to make real change look at the problems
we've got in this country frequent
flooding across the north of England
we've got to start getting serious about
working with other governments to tackle
climate change we've got trade policies
that don't end up sustaining good jobs
that allow people that enough for money
to raise a family on these are things
that directly affect people's lives and
the only way to solve them is to go and
work with other like-minded governments
in order to build a fairer system across
the world that's always been a core part
of Labor's tradition over the last
hundred years and it has to be again not
least because so many of these problems
that people now face can only be solved
at that Global level